we're gonna in principle make the most
boring 60 symbols video because we're
going to talk about watching pain dry at
a macroscopic level watching pain dry is
as you know an incredibly boring thing
to do at a microscopic level i want to
try and get across over the next few
minutes that not only is it interesting
it can be fascinating
so we've got latex white paint so what
this is is
one micron sized a thousandth of a
millimeter sized spherical particles of
polymer
in water so that's the simplest possible
paint you can use and for physicists
that's what we really like doing we
really like in the throat
the the the the difficult chemistry and
really let's focus on what the what the
physics is here so i'm going to take
some of the paint and to make it make it
more straightforward and easier to see
what's going on i'm going to take this
paint and what i've done is i've diluted
it down slightly i've added some just
basically water
increase the magnification now
you might be able to see these little
things moving around those are the
individual particles let's try and focus
in and you can see they're already
collecting at the edge
we should be able to go even increase
the magnification even more
so each one of these is one of those
individual micron scale
micron diameter particles and you can
see that they're moving across you can
see them moving around in the solution
and they're joining on here they're
aggregating at the edge they're falling
out of solution and as we move this in
out of focus we can see now there's our
second layer building up at the edge and
you can see these little
they're joining as the droplet dries
what's happening is that this what we
call the the the wetting front or the
the the the contact line between the
solvent the substrate and air is moving
the droplets drying
and so we're going to see some very
interesting things happen but it's
moving as the droplet busy the droplet's
shrinking
and we're looking at that shrinking
process so that's moving in real time
and that's moving in real time that's
absolutely moving in real time yeah and
you'll see it starts to become pinned
let's try and focus on that here's
another pinning event
where you can see and then it'll
suddenly let go and these pinning events
are very very important where the the
the
edge of the droplet wants to move back
but sometimes there's an inhomogeneity
or there's a piece of dirt or there's a
defect at the surface which pins it and
stops it moving and sometimes that can
and in many cases what stops it moving
is when the the the particles themselves
pile up at the edge must point out that
the colors we see here are false colors
these aren't actually the colors of the
solution it's the way we're doing the
experiment we're playing around with
polarization to improve the contrast so
these really aren't on um
the colors aren't true colors are such
and in fact you can map the color that
you see onto the thickness of the film
but this is it's exactly this type of
process that
stated really the state-of-the-art
nanoscience in some aspects of
nanoscience is trying to exploit this
part process with nanoparticles so that
you can lay down regular lines um of
nanoparticles much much smaller
particles than this on on surfaces
when we have a droplet of the paint on
the surface as we have here and when
you're painting it on the wall you get
many many many thousands of droplets and
you love sort of thin films of of
particles and solvent
but the key thing here is again here's a
nicely wetting event or a deep pinning
event you can see what's what's
happening here is it's piling up let me
sorry brady to keep interrupting
so it almost looks organic this is
purely it almost looks like it's living
i think but it's it's purely inorganic
it's just water and and particles but
with fluid dynamics
it does remarkably interesting let me
chase the let me chase the front again
and this is a very very small droplet
again more pinning events in this case
it's leaving particles behind you see
the particles leaking out and being left
behind
oh that's a really nice one
that's really nice see them just
dropping out and you can see that the
the solvent thinning down so in terms of
painting this is this is the painting
this is in essence the painting process
where you want to you have particles in
a solvent you want to get those
particles you spread them on the wall
and then you want the solvent to
evaporate and here we go so
oh it's moving around that's very
interesting so you can see here now it's
stopped we've got a lot of solvent
motion still over here
and you can see the layers the various
layers
of the of the paint particles you can
see here it's all piling up so as i'm
changing the focus we're just going up
the drop you can see it moving around
that's possibly because i've been moving
the focus quite a bit
and now the last part
so that's the last part of the drying
what we had was that what's making this
white is the
um the way that the particles scatter
the light so we started off with that
suspension of particles in water so all
we've got left behind are those those um
latex particles and if we want to look
at that droplet how it's dried we're
looking at a dried drop of of paint
what excites me about this is that a
process that seems so mundane boring
uninteresting when you look at it in the
right way it is absolutely fascinating
and that i guess is what physics is all
about it's taking all the stuff that
happens around us in the real world and
trying to understand it and try and
interpret it and to a certain extent
trying to control it and i guess that's
if the fundamental reason i'm most
excited by that is that you've got the
most boring thing or what many people
consider the most boring thing when you
look at it in the right way and you
think about the physics becomes
unbelievably exciting